after your character dies you look you
shot it it was hard it was probably
intense yeah did you ever think that
that scene would be a tenth of like as
big as what it became no idea no
way no I didn't know any of it when you
saw it before it all came out and
everybody else commented were you like
people are gonna be talking about this
one well we started to so that was the
big episode that I was in and my
character had a lot to do and they
started the network started to sort of
talk about the performance and like it
was like people were getting excited
about it so we were invited
to watch it in a room it was me my
managers my agent at the time is Brent
Morley I'll never forget it and we
watched it
and all of us
were on our feet like hands over mouths
energy like we were shocked